[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
on these silent carried along by Oh
friends to Our Lady of sin
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and then sorry
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
magnificent father managed a [ __ ]
[Music]
they say
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey what's up guys I hope that you
enjoyed what's probably my favorite
video that I've ever worked on and if
you could stay just a minute longer to
listen to why I like it so much that
it'd be great so what makes this video
different is that it was a collaborative
effort it's a piece of original content
that exists not just because of me but
because of people with different talents
people who understand this game and
people who are a part of the community
just like you I wanted this video to
represent a few things I think it
represents how even two years after the
release of Dark Souls we're seeing
content that is just as good or better
than the content that was produced when
the game was released and that's a rare
thing not many games can inspire this
much creativity
what's even rarer though is you guys
you're all still supporting and
appreciating this content and that's
what keeps people like me going there
aren't many games with a fan base like
Dark Souls and it shows so I reckon
there's two things that you should do
right now one do yourself a favor and
download the song you just listened to
it was created a few months ago by a
small band called tanooki suit
the entire song is available on Bandcamp
in a pay what you want format so you can
download it for five cents or five
dollars whatever you think it's worth to
you remember that these guys created
this song not knowing whether it would
get popular not knowing if anyone would
even listen to it
show them the depth of your appreciation
whether you've got a bit of money to
spare or not it's a great piece of
content and with your help I'll be able
to convince other musicians or artists
to create content for this community
secondly the animation loops in this
video were provided by a youtuber named
vasila cough he's a talented animator
and you'll see way more of what he's
capable of over on his channel in the
next few months to my knowledge he's the
only animator who's devoting his time
exclusively to the souls series so let's
show this Dark Souls animator our
support click the second link in the
description and subscribe to his channel
he already has some hilarious Dark Souls
animations that you should check out and
I know he has some great ones coming and
that's it on a personal note though
thank you so much for subscribing
100,000 is an amazing milestone for me
and I am really lucky to be able to do
this I hope you keep looking forward to
what's coming in the future
until next time later guys we see the
struggle of others and hold around us as
they fight for the things important to
them there's a man who fights on behalf
of his broken homeland another who
fights to prevent his kingdom being
broken one man believes in research for
the sake of knowledge
- maybe this knowledge will give you the
power to fix your mistake